qué vale
[Aplausos]
cientos de residentes iracundos cantan
dios es grande y pillan venganza
mientras cargan los cadáveres de tres
hombres que murieron a manos del
ejército israelí en la madrugada del
viernes es un crimen enorme podría haber
evitado matarlos podrían haber disparado
a las ruedas del coche esto es un crimen
dios es grande que dios los bendiga
mucho otras personas resultaron heridas
las falsas israelíes dicen que los tres
hombres que iban en este coche ahora
acribillado abrieron fuego y ellos
respondieron con munición real
[Música]
las tropas de golán y en varias unidades
patrullaban por la amplitud de jenín en
otra noche de detenciones
el sábado con hotz
una de las unidades divisó un vehículo
sospechoso lo que generó un
enfrentamiento en el que los mandos
lideraron desde el frente
y secuestró un escuadrón terrorista vivo
el ejército israelí lleva a cabo
frecuentes incursiones nocturnas en
jenín y otras partes de cisjordania
después de una serie de ataques
terroristas mortales en israel la que
mató a 19 personas en los últimos dos
meses las autoridades palestinas
sostienen que en el mismo período han
muerto 30 personas en territorio ocupado
esta es también la región donde la
periodista de al yazira shirín agua que
fue asesinada a tiros el mes pasado
mientras cubría una operación del
ejército israelí las conversaciones de
paz entre israelíes y palestinos están
congeladas desde hace años y los
recientes atentados contra ambas partes
reavivan aún más las tensiones